[Musique]
benzema le meilleur d'ailleurs du monde
mais maintenant on se lance dans
l'espionnage
c'est très malin inspiré de faits réels
il ne s'agira pas d'une guerre 2 0
rencontrer les personnages de plus
diabolique de l'histoire
là ça ça gavrilo princip sa faiblesse le
lancer plus
sa force avoir démarré la première
guerre mondiale la super espionne
mathari cette force
sa présence à l'écran
sa faiblesse les échasses vous oubliez
vos bonnes manières je plaide coupable
est un moine fou
en raspoutine est forte
[Musique]
vous allez devoir les découvrir par vous
même ce délit s'il nous est
le 29 décembre nos ennemis france que
nous sommes des gentlemen
il est temps de leur rappeler
qu'ils sont 15 mhz
[Musique]
couvrez les origines
une semaine
[Musique]
les hommes sont toujours tellement
brouillon
the king's ma première mission le 29
décembre exclusivement aussi débat